first of all welcome hi everyone it's
good to be back is my first lecture
since coming to st. Louis I arrived just
before the Super Bowl and I'm in
recovery mode as you know I'm from
Seattle and that was pretty brutal
I mean that was OH oh boy okay so one of
the things that I was conceiving for
tonight's lecture which is on end games
was to do some to look at some rook
endings and as it so happens right now
today there was two wonderful examples
that I think I'm online right I can go
out to chess base website and download
them there was two really wonderful end
games that were played one was from
Gibraltar David Howell was white and
Hikaru Nakamura was black and I'll set
that up in a moment and then also Magnus
Carlsen today played a game where it was
four versus three a rook ending which he
won very very easily and we always
thought that you know all rock endings
are drawn okay they're rook endings are
when you think about the body of endings
so to speak and you think about Queen
and pollen games minor piece endings
rook endings King and pawn in games and
so forth and so on you discover that
statistically speaking literally half of
all n games tournament end games come
down to rook and pawn endings Wow I
don't know why that is I mean you said
look at a chess set and you see all of
these pieces and you go mmm
half of the time we're going to get to a
rook and pawn ending pretty remarkable
so I wanted to talk about rook and pawn
endings and in the same measure
in the same way that I do
opening analysis I like to have a guide
somebody who's going to guide me through
the endings so when I think about
players who played rook and pawn of
endings I think about three players I
think of three players who do you guys
think of just throw out some names that
you might think are good rook upon end
game players Smee sloth kappa blanka
Kramnik I heard I think of three I think
of Smee sloth I think of Korchnoi Viktor
Korchnoi and I think of Akiba Reuben
steam the most remarkable thing about
Akiba Rubinstein is I was just reading
an article The Scotsman The Scotsman
from John Henderson
it was explaining that Akiba Rubinstein
played something like nineteen hundred
and fifty tournament games very
impressive about seventeen hundred and
fifty of them came to recoup on anything
like whoa that guy sure played a lot of
recompiling games as it's me sloth ad as
did Korchnoi this end game that I've got
obviously widest stance superior he has
an extra pawn and I've seen the white
players win this position often which is
really remarkable because Daniken
Philidor from the 17th century hi
welcome Daniken Philidor from the 17th
century had already shown how you're
supposed to draw this position while
you're black what you do is very simple
you put your rook
well let's let's give quite a move then
you put your rook along the 6th rank or
the 3rd rank and you just keep it there
and white we're going to make some moves
for white check and you step back ok and
basically white has reached the zenith
of what is possible for him and he
advances his pomp the moment that he
advances his pawn to the 6th or the 3rd
rank then the drawing procedure is you
just go behind the opponent you play
rook down and the whole point is which
is going to make some moves and you get
the idea that there is no place for
White's King to stand if we go back for
a moment to here and we're going to go
here here check and let's say white
waits ok and now all black has to do is
wait he can just wait anywhere with his
rook along this rank this Philidor
pardoning this Philidor treatment of
just waiting and waiting until your
opponent advances the pawn is absolutely
critical and you must know this ending
to be able to save rook upon endings so
this is a crucial one another crucial
ending let me just clear the board all I
have to do is type s yes save sure ok
clear board yeah is let's imagine
there's a white book there's a palm
there's a king there's a king and
there's a rope okay
so in this position it's black to move
and draw this position was considered a
win for white before incorrect showed
how to draw it essentially what black
has to do is check on the sides notice
that there's no area in the board that
the white king can escape so we're going
to go check king check King and now we
wait okay so for for a for white to win
the rook the king has to be over on the
Queen side as soon as the King moves to
the Queen side we keep checking the
black black keeps checking the white
king by from the side so for example we
might see say check here and we wait
yeah so if a certain moment White's King
has to walk over to the Queen side to
escort the pawns and we keep just keep
checking from the sides the reason I'm
showing you these two examples is
because of this game of David Howell and
Hikaru Nakamura that I'm about to get
from the website so is this okay or do
you want me to flip it flip okay so
clearly he karo
where the black pieces is trying to win
and we had this amazing amazing sequence
of moves that went like this rook h1 oh
okay I'm going to do this this this is
this okay so it's black to move and
Ricardo played rook h1 okay so we
understand the drawing checking device
that white needs to make the problem is
at the moment is that the king is very
very close to white rook so in an ideal
world the king would be on b2 the rook
would be on c5 and then we would have an
extra file for which we could check the
black king away what happened in the
game was very strange was that rook h1
what white should have played was rook
d3 check King efore rook c3 and now he's
getting his rook to the file where he
can keep checking the black King what
David Howell did instead was he played
King b2 and now
hikaru had a had a winning moment I
should say that Hikaru was on a winning
streak he had won six games in a row in
Gibraltar and in my career I had won
only bless you bless you in my career I
had had streaks of six wins three times
I remember having this conversation with
against grandmasters I mean I remember
having this conversation
with anatoly karpov plus you that what
was anatoly's win streak and he had won
four and i said well i won six in a row
and anatoly said well i bet you the
grandmasters you beat weren't very good
so funny you should mention that because
one of the streaks included you said
okay if we're pretty good but ii karo
was about to win his seventh game and
i'd like to ask you what what move
should hikaru play at this moment so how
many of you would like to put yes in
then king e for okay let's analyze if
you go Kimmy for I'll move my room to c5
yeah can't go ahead
king d4 okay I will wait how exactly am
I supposed to wait I'll move my rook
see this is kind of a bit of the problem
that black runs into he is going to need
his King over on the Queen side in order
to when he's threatened to move and
promote the pawn that he'll be able to
win the rook at the moment the King's
far away
go ahead yes rook h2 check okay I'll
wait I'll go King here actually I think
I should actually wait with my King on
b1 I apologize just so that I can be
able to check on along the third and
second ranks
King c3 so I'll check
King before and I'll wait
so the idea is that I'm waiting you can
move your king if you like I'll wait
some more King and I'm waiting for you
to advance your pawn to h3 and then I
just want to give you a whole lot of
checks a whole lot of checks also let me
just point out one other very important
positions
once I get my rookie when you're in this
position where you're your rook is boxed
in being in front of the pawn there's no
place for your king for the black king
the moment the black King arrives on g2
so you can liberate your rook I'm going
to give you checks so for example I will
wait I will wait and now you're here so
now you're ready to move your rook and
then advance your pawn so the moment you
come here okay excuse me I'll give you a
check
yeah and I'll just keep checking you
until your king is no longer protecting
the pawn on e7 and I'll get behind so
pushing the pawn too soon when your
looks in the way doesn't get you a win
let's go back to the position at hand I
think we were here and let me just see
what actually I think it was what was
played in the game let me just see what
was played in the game
was a chore played King bee - King bee -
that was a blunder that was the blunder
he should have played looked III now
we're talking about a world-class
Grandmaster making a mistake in a
basically very simple rook ending king
bee to h4 okay new main light and then
came this horrible rook default King III
h4 no I I wanted to be precise I
remember the result I remember what
happened but the actual precise moves I
wanted to be precise about so here rook
before and Hikaru played a horrible move
that gifted away his victory okay he's
right at the on the edge of winning and
what move do you think he karu played
correct
that was the move he played which was
terrible which was very very sad
what Hikaru needed to play what did he
coral need to do remember what his
problem is his problem is is that his
rook is in the wrong position and that
he needs to be able to move his rook so
that his king could end up in front of
the pawn and then he will win the game
he can't move the rook for the moment
because it's tied to this pawn so what
should he karu have done h3 and the
entire difference is that after rook
check where do we move our King
let's see what happened in the game King
III rook c4 and now he has his drawing
position
so because h3 rooks III check h3 rook c3
check King d4 illegally and the player
soon made a draw because White has his
ideal setup whenever the King goes back
over here you're over here and you're
making checks from the side so this rook
ending was a real surprise and had
Hikaru won it he would have beaten my
streak of seven and matched the streak
of Fabiana car you wanna at seven
so I recall talking my conversation with
Anatoly Karpov about his number of
victories at four in a row and at the
time that we had the conversation we
didn't realize that that in 1994 he
would win six in a row in Linares so he
was very chuffed about that and reminded
me that now he had he had gotten the
same number of wins but at the time we
had our original conversation we both
looked at each other and said can you
imagine Bobby Fischer winning 20 in a
row and it's all he said no it is not 20
in a row but that was one from hikaru
another one I wanted to show vikon's a
is a small coastal town in Holland and
they had a very very big chess festival
that recently ended and I was there oops
that was not what I wanted two kings two
kings I was there doing commentary live
broadcast
of the festival and this position or
something very similar to it had
occurred oh yes okay go away and this
was classic okay so it's it's Game one
it's round one
Vasiliy Yvan Chuck is white beador yo
bhava is black and it's yoga at jehovah
and it's clear that whites rook in a
rook ending what is really bad normally
speaking in rook endings it's really
crucial that your rook be active that
yeah all those pawns blocking everything
up and white is doing his best to save
the position and for example after move
like a five a four this rook oops excuse
me escape this rook on a three is tied
to this pawn and white should be very
careful about advancing the pawn too
early because then the black king is
going to get back and save the position
so I was thinking that white would try
to play the move King d6 and then after
for example pawn takes pawn takes rook
over White has good good drawing chances
to try to draw the game instead and this
is very critical to understand in rook
endings there are often those moments
where you can offer the trade of rooks
right and you go into a kyun pawning
game but King upon etting games of those
endings where you burned your bridges in
other words once you're in a king upon
endgame either it's lost or is drawn or
one right I mean there's no I'm going to
outplay my opponent anymore you know
you're in the soup so I was thinking
that black was going to play the move
a5 a4 and I went and looked at some
other games I came back and while doing
the commentary I mean and black had
played rook a for a trade of rooks now
how many of you think this was a good
idea by black to offer the trade of
rooks how many of you think it was a bad
idea I thought it was a bad idea
yeah but I wasn't too sure I mean there
are times that for example rook takes
pawn takes it's going to be very awkward
for White's King to to handle these
pawns so Vasiliy started thinking and I
was trying to understand the position
for example after rook takes pawn takes
now I've got to stop this a pawn King to
c4 now King to c6 and it's clear that
blacks King black is going to use this
pawn as a decoy to bring his King here
and to try to eat all of White's pawns
sorry but it's captured or in this
position I could also play this move
this move might actually be more
accurate pardon me
it takes King here
and I was I hadn't come to a conclusion
only it just felt wrong to offer the
trade of rooks went on to analyze some
other games and I was told a von Schaack
one Jew bova resigned like what
so in this position Vasily had just
captured the rook and de boville resign
like what's that you don't resign you
take the rook later you can resign you
can always resign but why resign right
here but take the rook first and then
resign and so now I was trying to figure
out what's going on if I take the rook
King c-4 take the pawn take the pawn
king c6 you know like what's what should
white do and then suddenly instantly
there was vastly in the studio hey come
on over Vasily congratulations on your
win could you show as the game and he
did a magnificent job he went through
the game explaining all of the
intricacies and the key moments and and
why he was worse and did it and then I
said well thank you very many finished
and I said well thank you very much
mathlete but could you explain for the
audience why black resign yeah yeah and
Vasily went and I said well thank you
very much Vasily but could you take it
one move at a time and he said sure
so he said rook takes a four pawn takes
King c4 takes on that five takes on that
five king c6 I intended to play King d3
uh-huh and after King d5 what move did
Vasily have in mind
six whoa takes and now what move did
Vasily have in mind f6 correct
and now after King d6c four and now
after E 5 c5 check and after King here
c6
and after a three c7 King here s7 yeah
my what what what what you should queen
with check and then after takes queen
with check again and now you have queen
a3 so this was the broom and I said very
nice thank you very much Vasily that was
that was a very good explanation and he
said to me well any good Grandmaster
would see that insulted on my own show
like douche Thank You Vasily now the
funny part of that story was that a dear
friend of mine
Yvonne Sokolov he's a grandmaster 2700
he had been watching the show and he
didn't understand why
Yvonne Chuck resigned so when Yvonne
Chuck gave the explanation everything
was very clear and he started laughing
like poor Yasser you know then that next
day and Yvonne Chuck up our knees
Sokoloff Yvonne had gone to the
breakfast and at the breakfast was a
grandmaster
Yvonne Suraj Yvonne Sarich was playing
in the Masters group they were getting
their orange juice in their eggs and
stuff and even Saira CH asked a sokoloff
could you tell me why jehovah resigned
and you one sort of course just like
Yvonne Jacque had said and sorry
understood and and Sokoloff said and any
decent Grandmaster with seed like they
root the insults had ripple ripple
effects that went on and on now I'd like
to show you a game just a second that
was played today
it was the Magnus Carlsen game here's a
year is a very nice ending Magnus is
white Magnus Carlsen
he is white and he's a pawn ahead but
this is not the notorious rook and for
rook and three if we take this d4 pawn
and we put it on f4 it would be rook and
four versus rook and three and a very
likely draw with upon on d4 however the
positions and easy win for white and why
is it an easy win first of all it's a
passed pawn when the pawn is on f4 white
doesn't have a passport in the position
secondly White's King unlike in the
examples that we saw with Philidor and
with nakamura White's King is going to
have a very easy time finding a pocket
where it's nicely insulated and
protected for example the way we would
like to win the game is by bringing our
King to e4 and notice there are no
checks we would advance our pawn to e5
we to advance our King D through e v and
upon the e4 will move our rook check and
advance our King to f6 okay so we've got
a very easy plan in mind and black has
to do his best to try to so slow white
down one of the things that black might
do is bring his rook over to the H file
in order to harass the h4 pawn so let me
just see it was rook a5 to stop the King
from advancing rook F force rook b5
waiting could anybody tell me why in
this position black didn't play the move
King e6 I was wrong what so if you go
King e6
[ __ ] and I give check can I just take
the pawn ah ah look f6 check and then
you get my rook okay just wanted to make
sure you guys were on your toes
okay so rook b5 and white play d5 king
over efore and now White has his ideal
situation so what white wants to do
again notice that unfortunately for
black he has no checks with his rook and
White's King is perfectly comfortable
here on e5 notice also that the King can
yeah
enter through d6 or f6 the only thing
white has to do is swing his rook over
to a7 check force the King back and then
he gets to advance with his king rook t3
there goes the H pawn but the H pawn
doesn't matter
and here Michael gave it up because he's
just going to have rook takes f7 check
and two connected passed pawns this game
by the way Magnus just played a really
really wonderful game almost
mistake-free it's like the guy just
doesn't blow it he always manages to
find very meddlesome continuations to
put pressure on his opponent and he very
very rarely makes major mistakes so a
very impressive game and for me I look
out for these rook endings as they're
being played and it just was a kind of
coincidence that I was coming in today's
lecture to talk about rook endings and I
saw these examples being played today
another crucial rook ending that you
absolutely have to know is this one
remember that position where there was a
black pawn and there was a rook in the
way well now we have the classical
position it's white to play and to win
how many of you know this ending like
this this ending you should just know
like the back of your hand it's really
good yes I meant what do you think white
should do rook c8 check a very good move
indeed that was because I miss set up
the position any happier than to go to
the 8th yes okay so now we've got this
position and normally speaking what
White is trying to do is advance his
pawn and to win black's rook so let's
see how he would do that we'll just play
a few moves first
okay so we've got who did that that I
must be the guilty one just to know it
so we just had these moves rook c8 Shaq
King g7 came here rook here checking
here rook here on here now the point is
is white King needs to move out of the
promotion Square so that he could
promote his pawn
but the moment White's King moves out
like now he will just get checked all
whoops I like to move you will just get
checked and it will be an endless series
of checks until white king is forced
right back and we get this position so
white has to do something to prepare for
his King to come out and young man you
had rook where fo rook f4 okay so what's
the big idea of rook f4 away yes him
right so what the young man is saying is
this concept of building a bridge white
meets his rook to help him build a
bridge for his King to come up so check
King check King check King to d5 again
white is threatening to promote and so
after check we built our bridge so there
are certain rook and things that you
absolutely have to know this one is one
of them where your king is in front of
the pawn and how to promote your pawn
and to win it and also from the
defensive point of view the Philidor
position the Lucena position and so on I
do want to encourage you to study your
rook component games to know the really
basic ones where there's just a king and
rook and pawn versus king and rook so
things like what happened to Hikaru will
only happen to you you you deserve to
win a well-played game and to just you
know let let the winds slip away at the
last moment that really is hurtful and
the players that I think are fantastic
guides to rook and pound it endings with
the three I mentioned Rubinstein's me
Slav and Korchnoi I can certainly
suggest that kappa blanka belongs in
there as well but those players in
particular played rook endings
fantastically well fantastically well so
please do make an effort to study your
game